you have a new book
coming out on the changing brain
can you give a high level overview of
the book it's called live wired by the
way
yeah the thing is we typically think
about the brain in terms of the
metaphors we already have like hardware
and software that's how we build all our
stuff but
what's happening in the brain is
fundamentally so different it's um so i
coined this new term livewear
which is a system that's constantly
reconfiguring itself physically
as it uh as it learns and adapts to the
world around it it's physically changing
so it's uh livewear meaning like as like
hardware but
changing yeah exactly well it's the
hardware and the software layers are
blended
and so um you know typically
engineers are praised for their
efficiency and making something really
clean and clear like okay here's the
hardware layer then i'm gonna run
software on top of it there's all sorts
of
universality that you get out of a piece
of hardware like that that's useful
but what the brain is doing is
completely different and i
am so excited about where this is all
going because i feel like
this is where our engineering will go so
currently we build uh
all our devices a particular way but you
know i can't tear half the circuitry out
of your cell phone
and expect it to still function but you
can do that with
uh with the brain so just as an example
kids who are under
about seven years old can get one half
of their brain removed it's called the
hemispherectomy
and and and they're fine they have a
slight limp on the other side of their
body but
um they can function just fine that way
and uh and this is generally true you
know sometimes children
are born without a hemisphere and their
visual system
rewires so that everything is on the on
the
single remaining hemisphere what
thousands of cases like this teach us is
that it's a
very malleable system that is simply
trying to accomplish the tasks in front
of it by
rewiring itself with the available real
estate how much of that
is uh is a quark or a feature of
evolution like how
how hard is it to engineer because
evolution took a lot of work
billion trillions of organisms had to
die for to create this
thing we have uh in our skull uh like
because you said uh you kind of look
forward to the idea that uh
we might be engineering our systems like
this in the future like creating wide
war systems
how hard do you think is it to create
systems like that great question it has
proven itself to be a difficult
challenge but what i mean by that is
even though it's taken evolution
a really long time to get where it is
now
um we all we have to do now is peek at
the
at the blueprints it's just three pounds
this organ and
and we just figure out how to do it but
that's the part that i mean is a
difficult challenge because
you know uh there are tens of thousands
of neuroscientists we're all
poking and prodding and trying to figure
this out but it's an extremely
complicated system but
it's only going to be complicated until
we figure out the general principles
exactly like if you you know had a magic
camera and you could look inside the
nucleus of a cell and you'd see
hundreds of thousands of things moving
around or whatever and then you know it
takes crick and watts and say oh you
know you're just trying to maintain the
order of the base pairs
and all the rest is details then it
simplifies it and we come to understand
something
that that was my goal in livewire which
i've written over 10 years by the way
is to try to distill things down to the
principles of what
plastic systems are trying to accomplish
but to even just linger he said uh it's
possible to be born with just one
hemisphere
and you still are able to function
first of all just just to pause on that
i mean that's kind of that's amazing
that's that's uh i don't know if people
quite i mean you kind of hear things
here and there this is why i'm
kind of i'm really excited about your
book is i don't know if there's
definitive uh
sort of uh popular sources
to think about this stuff i mean there's
a lot of i think
from my perspective what i've heard is
there's like been debates over decades
about
how how much neuroplasticity there is in
the brain and so on
and people have learned a lot of things
and now it's converging towards people
that are understanding this
much more in europe much more plastic
than people realize
but just like linger on that topic like
how malleable
is the hardware of the human brain
maybe you said children at each stage of
life
yeah so here's the whole thing i think
part of the confusion about plasticity
has been that there are studies at all
sorts of different ages
and then people might read that from a
distance and they think oh well
fred didn't recover when half his brain
was taken out and so
clearly you're not plastic but then you
do it with a child and they are plastic
and so um part of my goal here was to
pull together the tens of thousands of
papers
on this both from clinical work and from
you know all the way down to the
molecular and understand what are the
principles here the principles are
that plasticity diminishes that's no
surprise by the way we
should just define plasticity you know
it's the ability of a system to
to mold into a new shape and then hold
that shape that's why
you know we make things that we call
plastic um
because they are moldable and they can
hold that new shape like a plastic toy
or something
and so maybe we use maybe we'll use a
lot of terms that are synonymous so
uh something is plastic something is
malleable
uh changing livewire the name of the
book is
is like so i'll tell you exactly right
but i'll tell you why i chose livewire
instead of plasticity so i used the term
plasticity in the book but
but sparingly because that was a term
coined by william james over 100 years
ago and
and he was of course very impressed with
plastic manufacturing that you could
mold something in shape and then it
holds that but that's not what's
actually happening in the brain
it's constantly rewiring your entire
life you never hit
an end point the whole point is for it
to keep changing so
even in the you know few minutes of
conversation that we've been having your
brain is changing my brain is changing
um next time i see your face
i will remember oh yeah like that time
next i sat together and we did these
things and
i wonder if your brain will have like a
lex thing going on for the next few
months like you'll stay there until you
get rid of it
because it was useful for now yeah no
i'll probably never get rid of it let's
say for some circumstance you and i
don't see each other for the next 35
years
when i run into you i'll be like oh yeah
that looks familiar
yeah yeah and we yeah we sat down for a
podcast back when there were podcasts
yeah exactly back when we lived outside
virtual reality
yeah exactly so you chose livewire
exactly i think exactly because plastic
implies i mean it's the term that's used
in the field and so that's why
we need to use it still uh for a while
but yeah it implies something gets
molded in shape and then holds that
shape forever but in fact the whole
system is completely changing then back
to uh
how malleable is the human brain at each
stage of life
so what just at a high level
is it malleable so yes
and plasticity diminishes but one of the
things that i
felt like i was able to put together for
myself after reading thousands of papers
on this issue
is that different parts of the brain are
have different
plasticity uh windows so for example
with the visual cortex
that cements itself into place pretty
quickly over the course of a few years
and i argue that's because of the
stability of the data
in other words what you're getting in
from the world you've got a certain
number of angles
colors shapes you know it's essentially
the world is
visually stable so that hardens around
that data
as opposed to let's say the
somatosensory cortex which is the part
that's taking information from your body
or the motor cortex right next to it
which is what drives your body
the fact is bodies are always changing
you get taller over time you get fatter
thinner over time you you might break a
leg and have to limp for a while stuff
like that
so because the data there is always
changing
by the way you might get on a bicycle
you might get a surfboard things like
that um
because that data is always changing
that stays more malleable
and when you look through the brain you
find that it appears to be this
you know how stable the data is
determines how fast something
hardens into place but the point is
different parts of the brain harden into
place at different times
do you think it's possible that uh
depending on how much data you get on
different sensors
that it stays more malleable longer so
like
you know if you look at different
cultures it's experienced like
if you keep your eyes closed or maybe
you're blind i don't know but
let's say you keep your eyes closed for
your entire life
uh it that then the visual cortex might
be much
less malleable the reason i bring that
up is like
you know well maybe we'll talk about
brain computer interfaces a little bit
and
down the line but you know like is this
is the malleability a genetic thing or
is it more about the data like you said
that comes in
ah so the malleability itself is a
genetic thing
the big trick that mother nature
discovered with humans is make a system
that's
really flexible as opposed to
most other creatures to different
degrees so if you take a an
alligator it's born its brain does the
same thing every generation
if you compare an alligator 100 000
years ago to an alligator now they're
essentially the same
um we on the other hand as humans drop
into a world with a
half-baked brain and what we require is
to absorb the culture
around us and the language and the
beliefs and the customs and so on that's
what
mother nature has done with us and it's
been a tremendously successful trick
we've taken over the whole planet as a
result of this
so that's an interesting point i mean
just to lingard that i mean this is a
nice feature like if you were to design
a thing to survive in this world
do you put it at age zero already
equipped
to deal with the world in a like
hard-coded way
or do you put it do you make it
malleable and just throw it in take the
risk
that you're maybe going to die but
you're going to learn a lot in the
process
and if you don't die you'll learn a hell
of a lot to be able to survive in the
environment so this is the experiment
that mother nature ran
and and it turns out that for better
earth we've won
i mean yeah we put other animals into
the zoos and we
yeah that's right yeah i might do better
okay fair enough that's true
and maybe what the trick mother nature
did is just the stepping stone to uh to
ai but
so it's that's that's a beautiful
feature of the human brain
that it's malleable but let's on the
topic of mother nature
what do we start with like how blank is
the slate
ah so it's not actually a blank slate
what it's
terrific engineering that's set up in
there but
much of that engineering has to do with
okay just make sure that
things get to the right place for
example like the fibers from the eyes
getting to the visual cortex or all this
very complicated machinery in the ear
getting
to the auditory cortex and so on so
things first of all there's that
and then what we also come equipped with
is the ability to absorb
language and culture and beliefs and so
on
so you're already set up for that so no
matter what you're exposed to you will
you will absorb some sort of language
that's the trick
is how do you engineer something just
enough that it's then a sponge that's
ready to take in and fill in the blanks
you